la contraofensiva continúa y se libra a
lo largo de esa gran línea divisoria que
hay entre territorio ocupado por Rusia y
Ucrania especialmente desde la provincia
de gersón y se extiende hasta el final
hasta ya la frontera original con Rusia
en la provincia de Luján sin embargo las
autoridades ucranianas dicen que estos
enfrentamientos y estas luchas se
centran en cuatro puntos específicos
algunos de ellos se han intensificado al
oeste de la región de saporilla otros
están centrados en esos límites de la
provincia de donest y de saporilla donde
se han liberado algunos pueblos en los
últimos días y otras son en batallas ya
bastante conocidas a lo largo de estos
meses como en backmud donde las fuerzas
ucranianas han logrado recuperar
territorios alrededor de la ciudad y en
el frente de criminal
en esos límites de la provincia de
lujangs donde tanto unos como otros
intentan realizar ofensivas sin embargo
los enfrentamientos en el país No
solamente se sienten en esa parte
estamos en la ciudad de donde es
originario el presidente por la siesta
como una de las muchas de otras ciudades
de Ucrania atacadas con misiles en esta
última semana Estamos en un barrio
Residencial como pueden ver este es un
parque infantil rodeado de edificios y
aquí en la noche del 13 de junio fue
atacado con diferentes misiles van a ver
algunos de los edificios que quedaron
destruidos a mis espaldas y como
resultado fueron 12 personas muertas y
más de 28 heridos al día dos días
después hubo otro ataque no solamente
área residenciales y no esta vez también
a áreas empresariales especialmente a
una gran fábrica de acero en la ciudad
pero como estos ataques se repiten en el
resto del país y especialmente enfocados
a áreas civiles como lo que podemos ver
en este momento